[Music]
louise is with us in new york city hi
louise what's up
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve how can i help
so i recently got engaged to my
girlfriend of
almost a few years
uh we've been living together already
for two years since i moved here to new
york city
um
we're both
in debt i have
just over 20 grand in student loans and
a little over 35 000 and
credit cards
i don't know how much she owes but she
has a couple of cards that are almost
maxed out or basically maxed out
i don't think it's
maybe just over 10
total she doesn't have any student loans
we don't have a
car
so any any other loans and we make about
150
uh
gross or i mean household before taxes
the question is i i've been following
baby steps or money makeover and i've
tried
to budget i have the app and i've tried
to
do it on my own
just for my finances i haven't really
been able to
follow through other than baby step
number one i'll stick to the budget
and uh
what do you mean what do you mean the
question is
77 okay
so why have you not been able to move
beyond saving a thousand dollars
uh
i think because i haven't um
cut out or cut up my credit cards
you're not living on them you wrote out
a budget but you're not living on it
right you're still doing the same old
crap after you wrote the budget and put
it in the drawer
yes yeah that's normal so i'm like you
already know what you gotta do to fix it
right
right yeah so my question is i wanna i
mean since we're now engaged then uh
we're getting married next may i i want
to
and i've tried to
to do it together i mean
she doesn't really manage on
on her own
i i wouldn't
i wouldn't combine your finances until
you're married
right but what about like budgeting or i
wouldn't combine your finances i
wouldn't combine your finances until
you're married
you shouldn't pay her bills she
shouldn't pay your bills
i i don't need that but like we have
household expenses and um
i mean well that's just splitting it
with your roommate all of that
that's just splitting it with your
roommate when she's your wife it's
different but right now she's your
roommate
and so how do best
um discuss with her
i mean even even if we're not combining
but how to best discuss with our
and adjust our lifestyle
because even if
we're going to be at odds where i if i'm
trying to do something but she's trying
i mean continues with our well what it
amounts to is you have to have a vision
beyond friday night
thank god it's friday oh god it's monday
you're living short term both of you and
when you start saying hey i think we
could be out of debt and i think we
could be wealthy and i think we could
work together and and this money piece
be a high level of communication and add
to our relationship and i'm going to
really start sticking to this budget i
haven't done a good job so far but i'm
going to write out my budget i'm going
to start sticking to it i'm going to
really do this stuff and i'll be
cheering you on i hope you do too
because when we're married we're going
to be doing that we need to be working
together to win long term because
couples who do not work together on
money usually don't stay married
and if they do they have a crummy
marriage
because if you can agree on your
spending and agree on your money goals
what you're really agreeing on is your
priorities your fears the things you
love your goals and you're ready to go
so uh i think the best thing louise can
do is work on luis right now instead of
fixing somebody else
because you got some work to do on you
brother
so get that budget out of the drawer
start living on it cut up the stupid
credit cards plastic surgery tonight by
candlelight
right in front of your fiance
you don't have to cut hers up you're
cutting yours up you're setting the
you're setting the trail you're setting
the
example